It's been a pretty heavy duty winter
for us.
It's been a little rough.
Whoa!
You know, just staying at home
and maintaining the farm.
Go, go, go, go. No!
The kids are kind of antsy
if they're cooped up for too long.
We're missing a chicken. I only count 29.
So it's important getting them out and
having a change of pace for a little bit.
There you go.
Just being on the farm all winter long,
we have been kind of cyclic
through these similar red meat cows.
And chickens and all that.
So it'd be nice to get out
and kind of change up the diet
a little bit.
Fish provides nutrients
that we can't get from our other animals.
And we've been in Alaska
for a whole year now.
So for the first time, we are going
to Mineral Lake to go ice fishing.
Moses.
Olivia.
Come on, come on.
Oh, he's on the way.
All right.
That's probably far enough
before we check the ice.
I don't want you going out
before I check the thickness.
I want to make sure it's safe.
But should it be okay
enough for us to be scooting across.
C'mon babies.
With everything that we've had to do this
winter, we've had next to no free time.
So having the opportunity to go out
and do something as a family
is just such a blessing.
I think I want to stop here.
I think this looks fine.
We're going to check
and see how deep it is.
Did you hit water?
I think I did.
I'm goinna check.
No, we're still at ice.
Whaaat!.
So the trick is to try the extension here
to see if that's any good
Oh, yeah.
Pull her up.
Just a little funky.
Oh, my gosh,
it's still not even touching water.
I'm wondering
if we're not hitting ground or something.
Is that like tar, flakes, stuff?
Either that or weeds or something.
All right.
Hole number two and move on.
All right, follow dad.
Hopefully we get lucky.